fin du conflit routier les barrages
levés partout dans le pays comme l'ont
demandé ce matin les deux syndicats de
transporteurs
les négociations reprendront le 1er mars
les dossiers européens le président
mitterrand reçoit le chancelier kohl en
ce moment même à l'elysée un accord sur
le démantèlement partiel des montants
qu'entre cette foire agricole pourraient
être annoncés ce soir vives tensions et
grève générale aujourd'hui au pays
basque espagnol après l'assassinât hier
d'un sénateur socialiste
les obsèques en présence du premier
ministre felipe gonzalez tourne ta une
manifestation contre le terrorisme liban
cessez le feu de principe mais de
nouveaux accrochages militaires à
beyrouth
même monsieur bonsoir
fini les barrages attention aux bouchons
sur toutes les routes de france les
poids lourds se sont ébranlés
aujourd'hui les camionneurs ont repris
le volant après une épopée de neuf jours
qui tenait en haleine les pouvoirs
publics et l'opinion
sans oublier les automobilistes hier
soir dans ce journal jacques delors
premier ministre par intérim parlant des
devoirs du gouvernement et des
responsabilités des routiers affirmer le
caractère prioritaire de leurs
revendications
ce matin les deux syndicats de
transporteurs jugeant qu'il s'agissait
là d'une ouverture appelé les routiers à
lever les barrages sur le terrain où la
lassitude et les divisions commençait à
poindre le rappel fut cette fois entendu
bruno l'aude réf
ils partent 8h ce matin sur l'autoroute
paris lille près de garonor à quelques
kilomètres au nord de la capitale
le dernier carré les irréductibles ceux
qui hier devant nos caméras déclaré
vouloir rester jusqu'au bout doivent
céder à leur tour mais c'est la rage au
coeur qui lève le barrage
trahi par nos syndicales comme
d'habitude et pour patienter on ce
mouvement là il n'aura peut-être pas
d'autres mais en fait on peut peut-être
nous croire un peu plus à l'heure
actuelle qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant qu'est ce que vous faites
vous travaillez ben oui j'allais
travailler vous croyez qu'on n'a pas
perdu à ses gros comme ça mais enfin il
a fallu attendre plusieurs heures avant
de dégager totalement l'autoroute et de
la rendre la circulation vers midi les
voitures commençaient à passer à 16h30
le pc de rosny sous bois annonce les
quatre derniers barrages viennent d'être
levée la route reprend son image
habituelle un peu partout en france
la région lyonnaise on lève les barrages
avec le sentiment d'avoir gagné la
lassitude
les raisons familiales se sont mêlés de
la partie je crois que tout le monde en
avait marre le gouvernement n'a pris
conscience
blagnac à jour amer sur l'autoroute
entre montpellier et narbonne
on a hésité longtemps ici on ne voulait
pas croire que les syndicats avaient
demandé la levée des barrages c'est fini
et bien fini
lorsque les gendarmes ont apporté les
télex des syndicats avec le mot d'ordre
lever les barrages
alors on a commencé à y croire dans
l'après midi
ici aussi on dégageait la route en haute
savoie le bastion routier le plus dur là
où tout avait commencé il ya neuf jours
à la suite de grèves de douaniers de
part et d'autre des alpes
c'est dans la confusion ou parfois dans
la colère mais dans le soulagement
général que les routiers décidèrent de
suivre le mouvement
sur place isabelle bechler le bonhomme
de neige des routiers en colère ne sait
plus où donner de la tête entre les
camions qui s'ébranle
il ne pourra pas résister longtemps aux
gaz d'échappement des poids lourds qui
lève le barrage après la victime la
fonte le guette en fait au péage de
cluses et routiers sont soulagés la
majorité d'entre eux n'attendaient
qu'une porte de sortie acceptable avec
la perspective de nouvelles négociations
au ministère des transports dès lundi
ils s'en vont maintenant aussi vite que
leurs 38 tonnes le leur permettent
évidemment ne dégage pas 3000 camions en
quelques heures à peine car il ya les
formalités de douane et puis le fameux
dédommagement de 2000 francs a touché
selon les responsables du barrage pas de
retour à la normale avant trois jours si
tout va bien
en repli tracé difficile pas seul il ya
énormément et qui avait surtout due à
l'autre côté de la frontière entre les
italiens et katia jocard de 1200 camions
alors ça c'est une affaire de la
gendarmerie et on va leur donner un
petit coup de main on leur a donné
quelques points guettait jo et où
personnellement n'est pas les aider
c'est ce qu'on appelle depuis ce matin
les irréductibles d'hier semble
aujourd'hui décidé à laisser la voie
libre aux vacanciers du week end mais
contrôleront t-il les derniers obstiné
les retours des vacanciers de février en
cette fin de semaine ne devrait donc pas
poser de problèmes autres que les
bouchons habituels aux frontières
italiennes il faudra cependant quelques
jours avant que les poids lourds qui
sont bloqués rentrent au trafic sa fuite
est normal même si exceptionnellement
les poids lourds pourront utiliser
samedi et dimanche les tunnels
frontières à l'hôtel matignon monsieur
de l'or a présidé ce matin un nouveau
comité interministériel pour examiner le
dispositif mis en place afin que tout
rentre dans l'ordre
comme prévu une deuxième table ronde
avec les syndicats de transporteurs aura
lieu le 1er mars
jeudi prochain comme prévu au ministère
des transports et toutes les
organisations syndicales concernées y
compris donc les syndicats de salariés
pourront y participer
et dès lundi prochain des discussions
techniques s'ouvriront sur les problèmes
de fond de la profession
dès son retour d'autriche en fin d'après
midi le premier ministre pierre mauroy a
réuni les ministres qui ont suivi le
dossier en son absence
monsieur fiterman bien sûr mais aussi
monsieur bérégovoy monsieur francis qui
est monsieur de l'or notre règle a été
celle de la fermeté 30 ils disent
monsieur maurouard ce matin à vienne il
n'en demeure pas mois il n'en demeure
pas moins que la mort que la durée est
aussi la nature très particulière de ce
conflit ont donné du fil à retordre au
gouvernement
c'est vrai le gouvernement a dû être
lui-même très surpris par le changement
d'attitude des routiers qui n'ont
pourtant rien obtenu de plus que la
semaine dernière mais il faut croire que
jacques delors a su trouver hier sur
antenne 2 les mous et peut-être
davantage le ton pour débloquer la
situation
il s'en était pourtant fallu de peu pour
que tout bascule il ya deux jours à
peine le gouvernement irrité menacé
d'employer la force est les routiers
n'aurait peut-être pas céder mais le
pouvoir a finalement résisté à cette
tentation
pierre mauroy n'a pas voulu annuler son
voyage en autriche il a misé sur la
lassitude des camionneurs c'était un
pari risqué
il la gagnait mais il ne crie pas
victoire ce soir et il a raison le
conflit n'est en effet toujours pas
résolu les routiers s'ils ont repris le
volant n'ont pas envie d'être sympa pour
autant ni vis-à-vis des ministres ni
vis-à-vis de leurs propres représentants
cela devrait inciter le gouvernement à
tirer les enseignements de cette semaine
folle qui l'a quelque peu désorientés
tout simplement parce qu'ils
connaissaient mal ou parce qu'ils l'ont
ignoré par dont les chauffeurs routiers
qui comme d'autres catégories sociales
et chauffeurs de taxi les artisans les
commerçants sont hostiles à tout
contrôle à tout encadrement et peuvent
réagir violemment sans préavis
et quand ils le font cela peut gêner
n'ont pas la vie d'une simple entreprise
mais celle de tout un pays
le gouvernement s'en est rendu compte à
ses dépens à lui maintenant d'imaginer
les moyens de prévenir ce genre de
conflit et d'établir des relations
nouvelles avec des hommes qui ont dans
nos sociétés dites modernes le pouvoir
de tout bloquer en effet quand une
corporation en découvre les pouvoirs
publics et l'opinion avec elle qu'elle a
les moyens de bloquer littéralement le
pays quand les relais syndicaux ne perd
pas parce qu'il s'agit de profession et
de mentalité bien particulière quand les
médias deviennent en fait une dimension
du conflit lui-même
la preuve est faite neuf jours durant
que le conflit des routiers n'a pas été
un conflit social comme les autres
martine gilson et daniel leconte alors
qu'ils répondent
sinon vous l'économie en l'air ok la
ministre pu en faire marche arrière
c'est qu'il ne peut pas faire machine
machine et dire qu'on ne veut plus finir
un mouvement un mouvement si on ne finit
sans cesse faire passer pour des cons
pour quand même comprendre quand même on
peut pas être là et définit mans pendant
une semaine vous les avez entendus
elle engage pas comme les autres pour
une grève pas comme les autres pas comme
les autres surtout parce que le moyen de
pression c'est le camion des 30 tonnes
que l'on aime parce qu'on y passe sa vie
mais des 30 tonnes qui peuvent asphyxie
un pays quand on les bloque au point des
routes un conflit pas comme les autres
aussi parce que les routiers n'ont pas
de tradition d'habitude syndicale ni le
respect des leaders politiques
ça fait deux fois qu'il se dégonfle deux
fois ont fait marche arrière et là ils
ont eu peur mais c'est mon chauffeur que
l'on pende maintenant c'est un désastre
à désastre je suis dégoûté pas de
respect des dirigeants syndicaux pas de
courroie de transmission et pas de
science de la négociation sauf peut-être
intuitivement pour michel vasseur le non
syndiqués l'homme créée par le conflit
permettrait peut-être d'aboutir
mais vasseur plébiscité dans son fief en
maurienne sera conspué lui aussi de
l'autre côté de la vallée
la première vue il semblerait qu'ils
soient et ferme mobile et il semblerait
qu'il ait l'enchère je ne suis pas le
seul frank ya beaucoup de gens qui
changent iguane l'envi un conflit pas
comme les autres enfin parce que
complètement médiatisé pour s'informer
les routiers écoute les radios et les
leaders leur place par le biais des
radiés et la cible un moyen de se
rassembler et aussi de faire circuler
l'information
pas de tracts sauf proposition fiterman
pour y croire il faut y voir notre
seconde de voir c'est aussi
d'accompagner le développement
économique
et je dois dire que parmi ces secteurs
celui du transport routier est considéré
comme par nous comme prioritaires comme
un secteur productif
après de l'or et l'appel des syndicats
la grève s'arrête et revendications
ayant presque toutes été satisfaites le
conflit sur la fin ne reposer plusieurs
rien il tournait à vide comme si sa
seule fonction était de montrer le
pouvoir des routiers et de l'expérimenté
jusqu'au bout comme si en somme il y
avait un enjeu quelque chose de non dit
quelque chose comme une morale
spécifique un code particulier à
respecter avant de reprendre
définitivement la route
ce conflit qui fait tache d'huile dans
plusieurs pays européens a montré aussi
la paralysie et les paradoxes d'une
europe communautaire dont le principe
fondamental pourtant et la libre
circulation le gouvernement hollandais
veut toujours réunir un conseil
d'urgence des ministres des transports
malgré le refus de la france
les compagnies d'assurance françaises et
étrangères vont avoir fort à faire pour
dédommager les transporteurs et aussi
les propriétaires des marchandises
longtemps bloqué le ministère de
l'économie vient de donner des
instructions aux préfets pour qu'ils
viennent en aide aux entreprises
touchées par les blocages routiers
les dossiers doivent être examinés sans
délai
il s'agisse d'entreprises de transport
ou non le dernier emprunt d'état fait
recette lancé samedi dernier pour un
montant de 12 milliards de francs il
vient d'être relevé à 18 milliards de
francs en raison du succès rencontré par
et auprès des souscripteurs
ce sont deux élections importantes qui
vont se jouer dimanche prochain à
draguignan et à la scène importante en
raison des résultats serrés du premier
tour en raison aussi du climat politique
locale empoisonné par l'agression dont a
été victime mardi dernier à draguignan
le maire sortant edouard soldats ni à
draguignan monsieur soldats ni qui
conduisent qui conduisait la liste
d'union de la gauche avait obtenu 48,30
2% des suffrages contre 45 64 % à
l'opposition conduite par monsieur klaus
trt les deux listes d'extrême droite
avait totalisé quelques 6%
mais au delà des voix il faut compter
aussi maintenant avec une volée de
plombs à grives sur place pierre alain
une espèce de calme à la fois pesant et
semble-t-il précaire s'est installé à
draguignan depuis l'attentât de mardi
dernier
c'est discrètement que l'on vous parle
de l'élection de dimanche comme pour
conjurer le sort
un autre drame dont personne évidemment
ne veut la tournure violente qu'a prise
la campagne dans l'ancienne préfecture
du var a entraîné un dernier
rebondissement
les membres du front national qui avait
frôlé les 5 % qui leur aurait permis de
figurer au deuxième tour on choisit de
ne pas choisir
ils rempliront leur carte à jean marie
le pen car ils ne veulent pas donner de
consigne de fautes dépolitiser
maintenant cette élection ce qu'il va se
passer dimanche c'est une arène avec
deux gladiateurs et nous sommes placés
en position d'arbitré dimanche prochain
par conséquent nous demandent de baisser
le pouce ou grimper et c'est une
situation qui nous est absolument
intolérable
combat des choses ou combat politique on
sent une inquiétude latente une certaine
nervosité dans les états majors des deux
candidats
discrètement surveillé par des rondes de
police côté opposition jean paul klaus
doit se dit menacé et dénonce la
violence d'où qu'elle vienne
ils réclament en vain pour plus de
sérénité le report du deuxième tour
qu'il considère comme un test national
je crois qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
aujourd'hui de campagne noble et
d'autres qui ne le sont pas il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui d'élections mineurs et
d'élections majeures
je crois que depuis mars 1980
incontestablement c'est vrai il faut le
reconnaître toutes les campagnes
électorales ont été politisée c'est
ainsi je ne vais pas souhaitait personne
ne lasse côté peut-être pas non plus mon
adversaire mais c'est ainsi on n'a pas
lu de kde de campagne électorale qui
n'est pas été politisée celle de
draguignan l'a été c'est incontestable
je ne le nie pas je dirais la limite
pourquoi pas oui c'est vrai c'est un
test national
et pourquoi ne pas l'imaginer comme un
test national de son lit d'hôpital à
marseille édouard soldats ni continue de
mener campagne sa permanence transmet
par téléphone aux habitants le message
d'apaisement qu'il leur a adressée la
manifestation de soutien qui a suivi
l'attentât a remis du baume au coeur de
ses amis qui parlent eux aussi de
nécessaire sérénité mais le combat pour
draguignan
nous notre préoccupation depuis
l'attentât horrible dont a été victime
le président édouard soldats ni c'était
de ramener le calme dans la ville vous
savez tous débordements étaient
possibles alors depuis mercredi après
midi
draguignan a fait la démonstration de sa
capacité de sa volonté à teneur est
calme et avoir cette ville
retrouvez tout ça paie alors c'est
important pour le scrutin de dimanche
je crois qu'il se déroulera dans le plus
grand calme
l'élan de sympathie qu'elle suscitait
vers lui l'attentât dont il a été
victime la décision de l'extrême droite
de ne pas se prononcer permettent
peut-être à edouard seul dany d'espérer
conserver son siège
mais si comme le disent ses adversaires
il s'agit de chasser une gauche est au
pouvoir ici depuis 24 ans le résultat
risque fort d'être serré auquel cas la
sérénité tant voulu n'est pas encore
revenu à draguignan à la scène aussi
l'attentât de draguignan va peser sur le
second tour du scrutin en second tour
qui s'annonce très serrée puisque au
premier tour l'opposition avait obtenu
46 points 50% des voix la majorité 48,37
et que l'ex un drop faisaient un peu
plus de 4% dominique laurie symbole de
la division politique du pays la scène
était hier soir fait en deux à la même
heure le meeting à 500 mètres l'un de
l'autre mobilisait les partisans des
deux candidats à la mairie
le même enthousiasme dans les deux camps
charge quaglia le leader de l'opposition
fait d'entrée de jeu le parallèle entre
ce qu'il appelle la gestion désastreuse
de la mairie communiste et le bilan de
la guerre notre milles de la scène c'est
aussi le replet de cet actuel
gouvernement socialo communiste
le seul problème c'est que pour nom cela
dure depuis 37 ans le leader de
l'opposition qui a obtenu 46,56 % des
voix au premier tour doit pour réussir
rassembler les suffrages du front
national 4,07 % c'est peu pourtant avec
ses 11 155 voix l'extrême droite
seynoise filmé ici lors de la
présentation de la liste peut assurer le
succès de charles quaglia c'est elle qui
détient dans une certaine mesure les
clés du scrutin
elle a d'ailleurs appelé selon sa
formule 1 faire barrage aux communistes
avec 46,36 % des voix maurice blanc doit
pour gagner avoir le soutien des
électeurs de gauche qui lui ont fait
défaut au premier tour parmi eux sans
doute des ouvriers des chantiers navals
déçus par la politique industrielle du
gouvernement
c'est à eux qu'il s'adresse en
adversaire accréditer l'idée que ce que
j'ai obtenu de mes démarches auprès des
secrétaires d'état à la mer ne serait
que promesses électorales également
électorale je confirme père fils et
filles reste que le parti communiste
joue ici une carte qui dépasse le cadre
municipal
va-t-il perdre un bastion un de plus ce
qui confirmerait une perte d'audience
enregistrés lors des dernières
municipales partielles ou au contraire
se ressaisir comme l'affirment maurice
blanc réponse dimanche soir
par ailleurs le conseil d'état a annulé
aujourd'hui les résultats des
municipales de mars 83 à sète dans
l'hérault et le conseil d'état a aussi
confirmé l'inversion des résultats à
noisy-le-grand noisy le grand qui comme
limeil brévannes a maintenant un conseil
municipal où l'opposition est
majoritaire face à un maire communiste
qui reste en place
on votera aussi dimanche prochain au
pays basque espagnol dans un climat plus
tendu que jamais hier vous le savez un
sénateur socialiste de 40 ans qui
conduisait la liste de son parti à ces
élections régionales a été assassiné à
san sébastian l'attentât a été
revendiqué par deux groupuscules
indépendantistes différents l'été à
militaire en a rejeté la responsabilité
mais dès hier soir le gouvernement
espagnol et le parti socialiste lui en
attribuer la paternité
le premier ministre philippe et gonzalez
s'est rendu aujourd'hui à san sebastien
pour assister aux obsèques de l'homme
politique a battu gérard in et felipe
gonzalez qui avait renoncé avant
l'attentât venir au pays basque étaient
présents aujourd'hui pour rendre un
dernier hommage à son ami personnel
le sénateur henrique casas l'émotion
était intense tout la direction
nationale du parti socialiste et des
milliers de personnes entouraient le
cercueil du sénateur
quelques heures auparavant le chef du
gouvernement espagnol avait demandé au
peuple basque de défendre sa liberté
face au fanatisme aveugle l'assassinât
du sénateur pèsera lourd dans le scrutin
de dimanche pour un grand journal
espagnol ce crime va transformer les
urnes électorales en urnes funéraires
en tout cas ces élections vont se
dérouler dans un climat de violence
jamais atteint depuis l'avènement de la
démocratie
d'un côté les irréductibles partisans de
la violence armée contre le régime de
madrid
de l'autre ceux qui trouvent que déjà
trop de sang a été versé
les résultats de dimanche montreront si
les partisans de la violence et du
terroriste ont marqué des points face à
ce qu'ils cherchent
nouveaux moyens pour lutter contre ce
terrorisme aveugle et la plaque
les combats continuent de faire rage sur
le front de la guerre entre l'iran et
l'irak
selon téhéran les forces iraniennes
contrôlent maintenant la région au nord
d'ace de bassorah en irak
l'aviation irakienne a riposté en
bombardant des villes iraniennes
le jeu des communiqués contradictoires
continuent
y at-il ou non un cessez-le-feu au liban
hier soir à damas l'un des médiateurs
saoudiens affirmait qu'une trêve allait
intervenir dès aujourd'hui de nouveaux
accrochages ont eu lieu au coeur de la
capitale libanaise et dans la banlieue
patricia cost
malgré tout la journée a été plutôt
calme aujourd'hui à beyrouth les
belligérants ont dans l'ensemble
respecté un cessez le feu qui symbole de
la situation au liban a été décrété à
damas mais n'a pas été annoncée
officiellement aux leaders libanais
d'ailleurs en fin de journée des tirs de
canon était de nouveau entendue à la
montagne et en ville sur la ligne de
démarcation de rafales d'armes
automatiques reprenait par moments la 6e
brigade de l'armée libanaise favorable à
l'opposition continue ses patrouilles
dans des routes ouest
l'aéroport est toujours fermé et les
soldats désoeuvrés profite de cette
trêve
le cessez le feu doit permettre aux
responsables politiques de débattre du
contentieux qui les oppose mais d'ores
et déjà un des leaders chrétiens camille
chamoun a pris une position
intransigeante
refusant tout répit un gouvernement qui
accepteraient une paix syrienne revenons
aux affaires européennes ce n'est pas de
l'europe des transports mais de l'europe
agricole que le président mitterrand et
le chancelier kohl s'entretiennent en
priorité en ce moment même à l'elysée le
chancelier allemand a répondu à
l'invitation du chef de l'état qui
parachève ainsi la préparation du
prochain sommet de bruxelles et le
dossier avec hull pourrait bien se
débloquer ce soir michel meyer longchamp
si le code n'est pas venu à l'elysée
avec les mavs il est arrivé à cas
certain nombre de concessions minimes
mais importante en ce qui concerne le
démantèlement des fameux montant
compensatoire qui défavorise des
agriculteurs français
il s'agit de permettre en quelque sorte
une convergence franco allemande de
donner le bon exemple par rapport aux
autres européens
l'objectif de toutes ces manoeuvres et
bien sauvé le prochain sommet européen
cette entente franco allemand de serre
dans le même temps la stratégie de
conciliation menée actuellement dans
toute l'europe par françois mitterrand
président en exercice du conseil
européen le président mitterrand doit en
principe annoncer ce soir le contenu de
l'accord auquel seraient donc parvenue
la france et l'allemagne fédérale sur le
dossier agricole
mais il n'est pas encore sortie de son
entretien avec son hôte allemand en tout
cas depuis le début de l'année depuis
que la france a pris la présidence du
conseil européen
monsieur mitterrand a voulu par une
approche nouvelle
animer une flamme européenne qui va si
souvent sous le poids des dossiers et
des blocages georges bortoli depuis le
23 janvier date à laquelle même cette
chaire est venu à marly françois
mitterrand rencontré en un mois tous les
chefs de gouvernement européens brève
rencontre
bref voyage de monsieur mitterrand d'un
bout à l'autre de l'europe
un vrai travail de fourmi que complètent
ce soir cette deuxième rencontre en un
mois avec le chancelier kohl
but de ces voyages d'abord montrée au
petit pays grèce danemark et c'est qu'il
compte dans la construction de l'europe
marque d'attention qui évidemment n'a
pas déplu deuxièmement en employant
cette technique du tête à tête dit
technique du confessionnal il s'agissait
de cerner entre responsables les
problèmes vraiment essentiel est de
laisser la technique aux techniciens et
troisièmement de favoriser l'idée
d'europe politique de volonté politique
européenne pour évidemment renvoyer la
technique à sa vraie place alors au
hit-parade de ce qu'on juge à paris les
bons européens c'est-à-dire ceux
justement qui sont sensibles à cette
idée d'une re politique on peut citer
les trois pays du benelux la belgique la
hollande le luxembourg on peut citer
surtout le chancelier kohl dont les
déclarations actuellement témoigne d'un
véritable lyrisme européens restent
cependant à passer l'épreuve la plus
difficile puisque au début mars
monsieur mitterrand va se rendre à
londres pour rencontrer une nouvelle
fois comme ça tu cher et que les
blocages éventuels reste entre les mains
de madame sainte cher alors est-ce que
même sa chair va se sentir un peu isolé
en raison du consensus relatif des neuf
autres européens
est ce qu'elle me lira un peu de ce fait
cela n'est pas certain bien sûr le
président mitterrand en tout cas se
rendra à londres le 5 mars prochain à
l'invitation de madame façe et on attend
toujours d'un instant à l'autre un
communiqué du président de la république
sur l'accord qui serait donc intervenu
avec l'allemagne fédérale sur le dossier
agricole européen mais il n'y a rien de
neuf pour l'instant un mot sur une
enquête qui piétine enquête sur le
meurtre de cette petite fille de 7 ans
enlevée le mois dernier en
lot-et-garonne à la sortie de l'école et
retrouvé 17 jours plus tard mortes et
violé un témoin était entendu depuis
hier matin il apparaissait comme le
suspect numéro un
en fait il a été relâché aujourd'hui par
les enquêteurs
l'état de santé de notre ami roger
couderc est stationnaire ce soir il est
toujours dans le coma à l'hôpital de
lyon où il a été transporté hier après
avoir été victime d'une hémorragie
cérébrale
passons aux sports maintenant avec le
tennis l'équipe de france mène
logiquement par des victoires à 0 dans
le match qui l'oppose à l'inde pour le
premier tour de la coupe davis qui a
lieu à new delhi yannick noah cinquième
joueur mondial a facilement battu en
trois sets ramesh krishnan 70e joueur
mondial en est le conduit à lui a dû
batailler un peu plus pour battre armes
amant d'arbitrage le frère de l'autre en
quatre sets l'équipe de france qu'il
disputera le double demain à
pratiquement assurée dès ce matin sa
qualification pour les quarts de finale
où elle retrouvera la tchécoslovaquie à
prague
beaucoup de tension et de pression
autour du boxeur louis acariès il est
vrai que le français va jouer gros
demain soir au palais des sports de
bercy puisqu'il va défendre son titre de
champion d'europe des poids moyens face
au britannique tony simpson qui est
réputé très dur à carrier sait qu'une
victoire peut lui ouvrir la porte du
championnat du monde contre le
redoutable américain marvin hagler et
c'est aux états unis comme il le fait
depuis trois ans que le français a suivi
un entraînement intensif
quand une personne
à new york louis acariès a la vie dure
pas de shopping de tourisme à son
programme
seulement l'entraînement
à part un footing à 5 heures du matin
dans central park louis ne sort de son
hôtel que pour se rendre dans une salle
de la 42e rue une salle bien connue des
boxeurs puisque mohamed ali lui même qui
a fait ses débuts c'est la deuxième fois
que louis acariès via dans cette salle
il y est connue et très appréciée
c'est un très bon boxeur très
intelligent qui en a dans la tête
c'est un boxeur qui a une bonne
discipline et des ressources illimitées
ici aux etats unis la boxe a fait partie
de la vie c'est aussi un moyen de
formation sociale pour les portoricains
elle est noire l'école américaine est
une école dur mais si lui et là c'est
surtout pour avoir la paix gelé ici pour
travailler et bien sûr je pense que je
récolterai esprit plus tard mais en
france année impossible car j'ai trop de
distractions trop d'amis c'est un pays
c'est un beau pays parce que c'est le
mien
ici je fais que travailler une enfant je
pourrais pas alors après jour après jour
louis acariès teste sa résistance
si c'est une épreuve pour lui fallait
aussi pour son père
c'est très dur je sais pas si je pourrai
recommencer a peur ce que je fais avec
loïs depuis 13 ans je pense pas c'est
vraiment dur est pour lui et pour moi
les pays autour d'un gâteau
niveau satisfaction pleinement
ces dix sept ans si louis acariès réussi
un parcours sans faute comme son père
tient tant il n'aura qu'un seul mauvais
souvenir
son entraînement anilha fin des
championnats de france de ski à auron
marie-cécile gros codognés absent à
sarajevo a remporté la descente dames
chez les hommes c'est la médaille de
bronze de sarajevo didier bouvet qui a
conservé son titre de nationale 2 c'est
l'homme spécial football tirage au sort
ce matin à paris des huitièmes de finale
de la coupe de france qui se joueront
les 17 et 21 mars prochains trois duels
seulement vous le voyez entre clubs de
première division
lens retrouve sa bête noire strasbourg
et mulhouse le tombeur de paris saint
germain n'aura pas la partie facile
contre bordeaux leader du championnat de
france
rapidement encore les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour l'ouverture de
saint-cloud demain le 2 le 5 le 4 le 18
le 11 le 3 le 19 et le 13 brigitte simon
état va maintenant nous parler du temps
mais d'abord des conseils traditionnelle
en cette fin de semaine où vont rentrer
et où se croisent et beaucoup de
vacanciers de février oui et bien fit
est assez pessimiste ces deux prochains
jours alors il vous conseille de partir
demain en fin d'après midi ou dimanche
en fin de matinée
mais d'une manière générale le réseau
sera chargé alors pour éviter les axes
les plus encombrés et surtout
l'autoroute a6 voici donc quelques
conseils si vous venez du briançonnais
de la maurienne et de la tarentaise
allions prendre la nationale 7 en
direction de moulins et de nevers ou
bien rejoindre bourges à partir de saint
pierre le moûtier par la national 76 et
à bourges prendre l'itinéraire bis léché
en jaune verte paris si vous venez de la
savoie et de la haute-savoie anna qu'on
continue sur la nationale 79 en
direction de moulins est à la hauteur de
digoin prendre la direction nevers pour
rejoindre la nationale 7
ou bien passer directement par
neuf prendre l'autoroute vers lausanne
jusqu'à nyon et en france rejoindre
dijon par la nationale 5 enfin pour
aller de dijon à paris en évitant les
grands axes prendre la nationale 71 puis
l'a19
à partir de 3 n'hésitez pas à appeler la
sécurité routière pour la région
lyonnaise le 16 le 7 le 854 33 33 pour
l'est le centre de metz au 16 8 762 11
22 enfin pour la région parisienne
le centre de rosny aux 16 1 858 33 33
beaucoup de conseils et puis vous devrez
prendre aussi en considération les
phénomènes météorologiques la brume le
brouillard l'humidité et le froid
autant nous en apporte le vent quant à
aux nuages nous en parle pratiquement
pas regarder la photo satellite c'est
presque un jeu ce soir il fallait
retrouver la france où cette masse
blanche heureusement nous l'avons
dessinée donc les nuages au nord ne
bouge pas et au su de la dépression sur
la méditerranée nous ramenait lé nuage
par l'est
résultat sur notre carte le plus mauvais
temps touchera l'aquitaine les pyrénées
le massif central les halles que la
corse le jura et les vosges en donnant
des précipitations fortes que ce soit
sous forme de pluie ou sous forme de
neige partout ailleurs quelques
éclaircies sur la bretagne mais surtout
des nuages du brouillard sur le nerd est
peut-être quelques coups de quelques
gouttes d'eau peut-être quelques flocons
neige mais en fait rien d'important
le baromètre est en hausse mais le
thermomètre baisse encore de 1 à 7
degrés sur la moitié nord et de 2 à 10
degrés sur la moitié sud
nous serons demain le samedi 25 février
le soleil se lèvera 7h41 se couchera
18h26 nous fêterons les roméo fois dont
difficile à porter en route demandant
pardon pour ce léger retard sur nos
horaires bel actualité bien chargée ces
temps ci je vous rappelle que vous avez
rendez vous avec hervé claude pour un
dernier journal à 22h45
demain 12h42 louis 12h40 cinquantaine de
midi et j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver à 20h très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2